持って行った
けどピョン藻前等
1大出しませんで知ってるかそうこれは
あのーいわゆる普通ドアたがしませんじゃない方ですあのイベントどうか祭りとかで
使われる
がちましーの方です
ついに俺も次に
ここができたらとなんとか好ましいよね
まあ家までご紹介するわけなんですけれども今日はね
まんまー皆さんの夢であるね金亨皆さん欽ドンとしてますか
きんとんって言うのはね雲のマシーンなんですよちょっとよと僕もよくわかんないんで
空食べるクモんがあるんですけど
まあ今日はね
はやはりこの方がします員がもう僕ひとりでも貸切が出来るんで
今日はまあざらめよねパティ記録ん
札を握る準備したんで僕度もメンツが張って検討を作るんでちょっとキンって正直者
っていうか心がきれいな人しか乗れないんですけど
ブーブー純粋な人なんてねマシーンで作ったね
キングでねっぽら駆け巡っていう動画を振ろうと思います
[拍手]
ブーブー is
[音楽]
鮫お皿目を見れます
[拍手]
[音楽]
王家にこれでもこんなもんが
大丈夫だからオンにした瞬間 z 4家だぞ
いきます
ございますまた王様パスマットの例えばやばいまぢやばい
じゃねぇ
いや勝ちだ
[音楽]
よしよしです
設定が出来たんだよ早速も入れていきましょう
実はこれがちだ
とりあえずまたガスしぼんできから結構時間との勝負だと思うんです金属が作れるか
どうか
ping 打っていきます
[音楽]
を記載いたしておりません
ポッケねぇなんか
[音楽]
うわぁ
ああどうでしていただきてきます
おねがいっ
やはりちょっと待ってとってもじゃあやります
ん
[音楽]
こんな感じでもガンガン作ってどんどんでかくしてきます
ちょっ小さくなってから時間との勝負だゾ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
フープ
うーん
[音楽]
やばいん
ん
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおおおおおおお
ツーを放った
あっひっぱん
ううっうぅうう
ああああああ
もう相撲人といいですちょっともやばいもうちょっとこんなもんにしておきましょう金
土うってこんなもんでしょ
bap ん
ppap
をん
はいみなさん何とかできたんですけど
ちょっとマットでかかったんだよもっとでかかったんだけどなんか
日でしぼんでいくんですよじゃあまた女だから女だからこう周知するんだけど早めに
店頭になりたいと思います
まあ正直もながらのれるで信じてるんですが早速
均等に乗ってみようと思います
はぁ
うん
おおおおおおおおおおおおお
おん
[音楽]
ん
美味しい